hey welcome everybody to the episode
it's the only late night show hosted by
someone who can do this
[Applause]
is it that you see that
yeah you used to do that to your mom and
dad yeah for you so terrible i scared my
mom because i was like hey mom mom my
hand and then i would do that
she was like oh yeah that was that kid
look
all mom and dads have to do a sit with a
bowl of popcorn and then be like oh
yeah oh
hey mom look
oh i love it yeah okay so before we even
said that
we were in studio 8g before i even
introduce tarik we are already off the
rails
you guys are in for it okay
we're coming to you tonight from studio
8g in rockefeller center and we have a
live studio audience
each one of these people is cuter than
the last
in addition to a studio audience we also
have a terry davis
you guys say hi to t-rex
it's so cute when they do it yeah derek
do you have any news i do uh this week a
guy in italy got the qr code proving his
coronavirus vaccination status tattooed
on his arm so i decided to do the same
thing
no way yeah yes i did give it a try okay
tarek this is a menu for a mexican
restaurant
yes it is i know you want anything yeah
i guess i'll have a margarita do you
want anything yeah can i get the nachos
okay all right
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
national senior citizens day was this
week celebrate by asking a senior
citizen what their plan is for leaving
afghanistan
outgoing new york governor andrew cuomo
left his dog behind when he moved out of
the governor's mansion this week said
cuomo i want to be remembered for a
totally different terrible thing
as part of an inclusivity effort new
zealand's men's soccer team has
announced a review of its nickname the
all whites
we have the same nickname said congress
i mean
the the all rights was right there
they're all rights all right we're all
rights we are all right yeah and then
you just have like
a a white person
pointing at himself hey
all right
a man in wisconsin recently set the
guinness world record for most
mcdonald's big macs eaten in a lifetime
here to comment is the man who
previously held the record for most
mcdonald's big macs eaten in a lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he truly is a clown tragic but beautiful
filmmaker ava duvernay turned 49 on
tuesday but she won't look 49 for
another 50 years
netflix announced this week that it will
release 42 movies between september and
december and oops you just watched them
all
it's over
according to recent reports a domino's
pizza ordered by a woman in england had
nuts and bolts mixed in with its
toppings
even worse under the nuts and bolts was
a domino's pizza
we'll talk about how tarik and i lived
in amsterdam later and domino's was the
only option and it was torture yeah they
don't know how to do pizza
oh this no this is really good pizza i'm
like you took a piece of the floor
and covered it in tomato sauce
also at dutch pizza hut um their their
pizza sauce was like watered down and
pink yeah y'all this is not what the
show is but today today it is today is
just a different show y'all do you ever
go to dutch dutch kentucky fried chicken
yes i went to dutch kentucky fried
chicken god what is that i don't know
all right
due to coronavirus rates in texas the
nra's annual meeting has been canceled
oh shoot
[Music]
and finally a connecticut woman told
reporters this week that a bear had
taken an amazon package of toilet paper
from her porch so please notify police
if you see this
bear yeah
and that was the monologue are you guys
liking the show so far
good
i'm so glad you are liking it because
there is so much more of it
now i'd like to get serious for a moment
um
it's been over a year since george floyd
was brutally murdered at the hands of a
police officer and yet the senate still
has not passed a police reform bill
there's talk of a framework for a bill
and negotiations but no real
action that's ridiculous they should
have passed the police reform bill by
now well maybe they're just having a
tough time getting bills passed in
general you know i thought the same
thing but that's not the case
that's right
there's been a lot of talk about police
reform
it seems like ignoring it is just the
norm
they haven't been able to pass a law
it's true
but there are a lot of laws that they've
gotten around to
like what the alaska tourism restoration
act to make sure that their tourism
still grows the 1921 silver dollar coin
anniversary act what's that
i don't
know we've got like seven bills about
lakes and storms but what hasn't passed
you guessed it there's no police reform
a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's not so many bills pass oh baby
shut your mouth we just get started
the faster act of 2021
to make sure that food is labeled
properly the transplant act of 2021
make sure donors are connected to people
in need the advancing education on
biosimilars act it probably took one
hell of a brainstorm
they even passed the future
which we may not get to see
if police reform don't get passed
quickly
go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
police reform it's something that we're
never gonna get
[Applause]
lest you think us liars misrepresenting
our officials
here's a list of the rest of the bills
that have passed without any issues
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wait what is that
national police week
national police week
yeah it's a week to celebrate police
before police reform
wow i thought y'all were just singing a
fun little song yeah it's real
our hopelessness is real
well dang
there's no police
[Music]
[Music]
there's no police
[Music]
[Applause]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]